[Music]
over a year after the first coronavirus
cases
some early patients are still suffering
long covert refers to symptoms that can
last for months or the return after
recovery
i was only in the hospital for a week
and yet months later i
still can't go back to work a new study
from wuhan china
has found three-quarters of hospitalized
patients
still experience at least one symptom
half a year later
what we're yet to discover is just how
long long covert can last
in the meantime doctors say get the
vaccine regardless of whether you've had
the virus or not
survivors know all too well how damaging
the sickness can be
even after they get better the road to
recovery can be long
and difficult peggy grain
is battling the long-term effects of
covid19
when she became sick in march she had
few symptoms but it's now devastated her
i life became really ill months later in
june
at the time i thought that everything
would eventually be fine
but things didn't improve i was
extremely ill for many many weeks
which turned into months without getting
better
[Music]
peggy is 48 years old and suffers from
long-term effects after covid
she sought treatment at a rehabilitation
center on germany's baltic sea coast
after the virus peggy felt fatigued she
suffered from dizzy spells and chronic
pain
in some cases i also had cognitive
difficulties like my head wasn't
functioning properly
i couldn't hear had poor vision and
couldn't follow conversations well
encounter
peggy has officially recovered from the
illness
but she says it feels like coronavirus
has stolen her healthy body and left her
with a sick one in its place
peggy spent five weeks here her main
goal is to get her life back on track
[Music]
you live your life five days at work a
weekend and so on
my life might be more intense than it
was before
i would like it to be as it once was at
the moment life is dramatically
different for everyone
and maybe i can still manage to get a
lot done
i'm sure that my recovery will allow me
to i think i will be a different person
than i was before
but that's okay
peggy green has since gone back to her
normal routine
but she still feels the lingering
effects of illness she often feels weak
and her muscles hurt but even if the
road to recovery is slow
she's glad to be on it
[Music]
dr david strain heads up the british
medical association's work on the
long-term impact of covert and is also a
survivor
we'll get to that in a moment first
david is there any way of speeding up
recovery for
long-term sufferers like the woman in
that report
that's a really interesting question
because we don't really know what the
natural history
of covid itself is of the lunk over it
is so i get many reports of people who
for example are taking multivitamins or
are taking
other health supplements and swerve it
has made a dramatic difference for them
but i also get reports from people
who've done no intervention
and have got dramatically better for no
apparent reason
whereas in all cases we get people who
don't get better so at this moment in
time
in the absence of randomized controlled
trials we don't have
any definitive answer as to what will or
won't work
well take us back to the beginning what
causes long covert in the first place
that in itself is a huge question that
may help us to identify what the
treatments are but
at the moment we don't fully understand
there are two or three different
hypotheses that are being run the first
and the one the
reason that i'm researching into is
looking at the mitochondria that is the
powerhouse of the cells
um effectively if you want to think of
them as the battery that powers your
body
basically we know covid the disease does
attack that battery
and what we believe is happening is that
there's a many individuals who that
battery just isn't recharging after the
diseases
it's like having the old iphone that it
doesn't matter how long you plug it in
for
it will not get the charge that it
requires and we think that's what's
going on
um and that's the theory we're working
on there are
others that think that this is an
autoimmune disease the antibodies you
create
to the virus then turn on the host and
effectively become like
rheumatoid arthritis or sle and trigger
an autoimmune disease
there are some that think there are
permanent scarring that takes place in
the lung
and the blood vessels that occur as a
result of the virus
the bottom line is at the moment we
don't know and
reality is it's likely to be a
combination of
multiple different causes what about
just how many people
this actually affects what do you make
of the chinese study that shows
two-thirds of hard-hit patients suffer
long-term effects
when you're looking at the hard hit it's
no surprise at all if you look at people
who've been on itu for other reasons
many of those will still have long-term
effects six or even 12 months later
i think what's more interesting in long
covered is the number of people like was
described there that
only got relatively mild disease i mean
for me personally i only had
one day that i needed any additional
therapy yet i've been left with symptoms
12 weeks later that are actually worse
than the initial disease
and and these are the ones that are
causing more issues
from the ons the office of national
statistics in the uk
they estimate that 20 of people who had
any symptoms at all are left with
some uh debilitating illness at six
weeks
and ten percent of people even though
they didn't require hospitalization or
any additional care
at the outset ten percent of people
who've ever tested positive
will have symptoms of long covey at
three months
and you've said this is happening to
younger people more women than men
uh those suggested to be at lower risk
exactly and that's part of the thing
that we're seeing particularly in their
um health care setting that
the risk of dying from covid is much
lower in females it's much lower in the
youngsters and therefore
in many healthcare settings these are
the people that we get to work the front
line because
if they catch covid the consequences
won't be as severe
but now what we're seeing is an after
effect is that these are
exactly the people that are more at risk
of long covert
in our study we've identified that even
though women are more likely to
self-present and self-participate in
study
even after we are just for that 86
percent of the long-covered that we're
seeing
is in younger fitter ladies and
and it does appear to be very similar
that all of the people who are coming
presenting with
symptoms of long covert were previously
very fit they were very active
we're not sure if that represents that
they have a higher baseline and
therefore
they they realize it a lot more if
they've been left with
some weakness or it may just be that
these are the people that are actually
noticing it because while most of us
around the world are in some form of
lockdown where we don't have
the same freedoms that we have normally
that we just don't notice how much that
this has had impact on us
just briefly you've also said this isn't
just a respiratory
infection it's a multi-system disease
are there steps that can be taken to
prevent long covert from setting in
we don't really know what the cause is
so it's very difficult to say for
certain but
one thing that we are trialling and
having good responsive with
is making sure that when you've got the
illness
you stay within your exercise envelope
or your energy envelope we call it
um for many other people training if
you're training for a marathon or if
you're
training for a race you want to push
yourself every single time
you train with long covid what we
believe
is if you stay well within your energy
window
then the window itself will get bigger
over time
rather than us trying to push because
one of the key things that all of us are
seeing
is the harder you push yourself the
longer it takes to recover
after each episode so stay within
your energy envelope at every available
opportunity
david strain thank you very much for
being on the show
you're welcome officials are
distributing madonna's coronavirus
vaccine in germany
it's being administered from tuesday and
is the second vaccine available here
still people won't have a choice they'll
have to take whatever comes
germany is facing criticism for a slow
start to its vaccination program
covert infection rates remain high
despite an ongoing knockdown
time for your questions now over to our
science correspondent derek williams
what's the difference between quarantine
and isolation
and what are the correct ways to observe
both
in the course of this pandemic these two
terms have been used interchangeably
quite often although they actually
mean different things and the confusion
arises because
both are protective measures for
stopping potential covet 19 spreaders
from transmitting the disease to others
so
definitions first isolation is defined
as a measure for keeping people known to
be sick with a contagious disease
away from people who don't have it
quarantine
on the other hand is restricting the
movement of people who
might have been exposed to an infectious
disease for a while
to find out whether they've been
infected or not um so
so both are waiting games the big
difference is
that if you have coveted 19 you're in
isolation
if you only might have gotten it you're
in quarantine
when it comes to the right ways to
observe them things get a little
trickier because different health
authorities and different countries
regulate the two in different ways here
in germany for example
if you've tested positive for covet 19
and are recovering at home
you have to isolate for at least 10 days
from either the day you tested positive
or
the day you began to show symptoms
though you can also
only leave isolation if a doctor
determines that your symptoms have
really improved and remained that way
for at least 48 hours
those who have been directly exposed to
someone with the disease for example
family members they're what are called
category one contacts and they have to
quarantine
and germany's health authority says they
should do so after their last
contact with the sick person for two
full weeks
um although they can also leave
quarantine if they test negative for
covet 19
after 10 days